hey everyone
welcome back to another video by simply
learning
in today's video we're going to learn
all about angular forms
do check out our other videos on the
angular series
so before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure to subscribe and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update
so first let's go ahead and look at
what's in store for us first
we will understand what angular forms
are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control
and group control and we learn all of
this with the help of a simple demo
so without further ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now i'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials
or your sign up forms or any sort of
registration forms etc
so forms are an integral part of a web
application
you need forms to update your profile or
to enter sensitive information
are also to perform any sort of data
related tasks
so now let's look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one so
talking about template driven approach
in this method the conventional form tag
is used to create
forms so angular automatically
interprets
and creates a form object with the help
of the directives
now controls can be added to the form
using the ng model tag
now multiple controls can be grouped
using the ng control group module
so it basically uses several module
classes to provide controls
now if you don't get this don't worry
you'll understand better when i'm
showing you the demo
next up is json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as json values
when the submit method
is called lastly basic html validations
can be used to validate the form
fields in the case of custom validations
directives can be used
so arguably this method is the simplest
way to create
an angular form so moving on to the
active approach
now this approach is the programming
paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the
anti-pattern of updating the data model
by a two-way data binding so it does not
use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous
and can be unit tested with synchronous
programming techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form
group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like
name age and location now a form control
is basically a class that enables
validation of these
fields for each input field an instance
of this class
is created now these instances help
check the values of the field and see if
they're either touched
untouched dirty pristine valid invalid
and so on
so this allows you to check every field
for the value
it makes it easier to understand which
field's value is invalid
or which field has not been entered etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls
a form can have multiple group controls
the form group
returns true if all the controls are
valid
and provides validation errors if there
are any so i hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features
i'm sure it will become extremely clear
once you look at the demo
so for that let's head to our vs code
so back in my vs code i've created
a component called form component and
i've also included the simply learn logo
just to beautify
the appearance so once you execute the
code
this is what you're going to see on your
browser so you just have the logo at the
moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to
import the forms module all right
so oh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is
so we're going to be creating a user
registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last
name email id and a password all right
so now let me show you how to import the
forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file you will have to
import
forms module from angular forms
all right and then in your imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that
let's go ahead and start our form
creation
so here in my component.html
let's enclose the entire form within a
div tag
so here let me say div
class is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now i'm going to create a div class for
every field
so say div
class equals form
group
i'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag for
basically it's the first name so let me
just
say first name
and the tab will basically have first
name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right so this we have to do for
all the other fields so let me just copy
this
and paste it like four times
i'll also add the tag
for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type submit
let's just say submit on the button so
now
let's go ahead and change these values
here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have password so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our uh user
registration form ready
but i would like to uh align it
to the center so let me just do that
so here in my css file i'm just going to
uh align all the div tags the center and
the label tag to the left so let me save
this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form with a logo
so this is how you create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
ng model
now this directive when added into the
input tag
will provide form controls to every
input
field all right so here let's just go
ahead and say
ng model that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for
every other field
all right let me save this and back in
my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like ng untouched ng pristine
ng valid are added right so this
indicates that angular has recognized
the form tag
and it has added these classes to the
form as well as all the fields
so this is achieved when you add the ng
model directive in your input tag
now back in my vs code now every form
has an
output property attached to it called ng
submit
all right so this property can be bound
within a method that
method called the subbit method so once
submitted
this method is called right so once we
click on the submit button this method
has to be called
so to include that we'll have to just
save
form ng submit
equals
submit all right
so now we have to define the submit
method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our
component.ts file and let me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function called
subnet
and then here let me just console log
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time
you click on the submit button this
method is called
all right so let's just have a look at
the browser so first let's go to our
console
and when i click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step
is to generate javascript representation
now we'll have to make use of another
directive called ng form
that is assigned to a template variable
okay
so this javascript representation helps
with validating all the fields
so i'll help you understand that better
so back in our html file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login all right
and say ng form
okay now the mgform object includes the
javascript representation
so now while you're calling the submit
method you're going to pass
login as a parameter so let's just say
login here
and in my ts file again let's just say
login and along with
it i want login to be displayed so
i say login again so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's
click on submit
and now here you can see the javascript
representation
so within form i can
check for email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you
all information about the particular
field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information
so we're going to learn about that in
our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that
incorrect fields are not submitted
is by disabling the submit button
correct
now apart from this you can also specify
certain properties in your input tag
for the corresponding input field
now um let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty
and the form only accepts names with the
minimum length of 2 and the maximum
length of
7 all right so here in my input tag
i just mentioned required meaning this
field cannot be
empty and min length
to 2 and
max length
to say 7 all right
so to check this let's go to our browser
and here let me submit the form without
filling the first
name and evidently there has to be
an error so when i submit it
and i look here what's in forms and here
controls and my first name
you can see that an error is shown here
it says required equals true
that means that there is one error now
you can make use of these form control
objects
you can leverage form control objects to
ensure field validation
and display a message whenever an error
occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these
objects like errors or invalid
or touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create a variable
let me call it
name and
let's say ng model
all right here the variable name
receives the control
object so here back in my browser when i
submit again without
the first name you can see that the
invalid
property is set to true correct
so this helps us use this property to
alert the user with the help of a simple
if logic
so back in my vs code
let me create another div
tag
within which i mentioned ng if
within which i'm going to use a simple
if logic so let's say
ngf
name which is our template variable
name dot touched
and name dot invalid
is true right
then i'm going to alert so i'm gonna
make use of an alert here let's say
alert danger
all right so in my css file i'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're going to have the background
color red
for danger all right and here i'm going
to display the message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name
it says invalid here so this was a
simple demonstration to show you
form validation of course you can modify
the code
depending on your requirement say
suppose the length of the first name is
too short
then you can alert the user with a
different message or
suppose they have missed out on filling
a form field then you can again alert
the user
so you can basically make use of the
nested if condition
right now just to help you understand
that better let me just
show it to you now back in my html
file instead of invalid
let me have another tag a paragraph tag
within which i make use of ngif again
now ng if name dot
errors dot required
is true then i display the message
first name
required all right
and if
the length of the first name is
not two
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2
then i'm going to display another
message so let me just say
name dot errors dot min length
if this is true then i'm going to say
sorry
short first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when i proceed without providing the
name it says first name required
but when i type in one character it says
sorry
short first name but if i type in
another character it accepts
so i hope this made you understand how
form validation
works so this was just a simple
demonstration again
now i highly recommend you explore these
properties and play around with these
objects
trust me it's really fun so i hope this
tutorial helped you out so with that we
come to the end of this session
uh thank you so much for being here
watch out for more videos
on angular and i'll see you next time
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here